page a lâché ni contre les armes c'est
bon alors oui j'ai une chance elle
sigéric ce que souligne c'est notre
journal pendant l'année 77
bon je pense vous allez me reprendre sur
le ferme journal non c'est à dire
journal si l'on considère le thème de
l'émission journal intime bien
évidemment comme le disait françois ce
n'est pas un journal intime je considère
moi que c'est un regard j'ai fait un
pari mais je me suis fait à moi même
c'est à dire d'aller d'un bout de
l'année à l'autre 1er janvier 77 1er
janvier 78 c'est-à-dire de m'imposer un
espace car autrement je n'aurais pas je
n'aurais pas pu tenir là je me suis
obligé je me suis discipliné pour une
seule et bonne raison c'est qu'on
m'avait demandé comme le demandait je
crois en produire à n'importe qui à
n'importe qui d'écrire mes mémoires j'ai
eu la coquetterie très content que
j'étais trop jeune et que à ce moment là
on a un peu insisté en disant que vous
ouvriez des questionnaires ils vont vous
interroger et j'ai dit que je ne voulais
pas d'un livre magnéto fans car mais
c'est très personnel c'est très
subjectif il y en a qui sont tout à fait
remarquable c'est pour moi une forme
d'imposture donc je me suis mise à
écrire et je remercie les mémoires et
les livres magnétophone time on condamne
à écrire voilà cet ouvrage alors une
sarsgaard une série de temps forts d'un
regard sur des hommes et des choses que
vous avez approché principalement dans
votre vie professionnelle
oui tout à fait je me suis promené j'ai
promené mon regard je me suis attardé je
ne prétends pas être allé du côté de
l'essentiel tout le temps mais je crois
que le titre indique bien ce qui s'est
passé c'est le temps d'un regard c'est
terriblement éphémère mais parfois c'est
également important et d'autre part
j'aurais pu parler peut-être de choses
qui sont beaucoup plus essentiel je ne
les ai pas vus cela ne veut pas dire que
je n'y ai pas pensé mais je n'ai pas eu
le temps de nous précipiter pour les
éclairs je me suis attardé sur ce qui va
vraiment vous prenez m'attirait me
séduise jean-marie qu'un amour qui
revient très souvent sous votre plume
c'est le mot sommes par exemple notre
foi en l'homme faire confiance à l'homme
à la hauteur d'homme ce sont les hommes
qui justifie les hommes les bonnes
terres de l'homme
oui je suis naïve de ces idiots suis
enfant mais c'est vrai parce que
maintenant la peur d'employer vraiment
par exemple les démos non on a peur
d'employer le mot amour on en pleure on
a peur d'employer le mot merci aux
mappeurs employer le mot sommes je crois
que ce sont des mots qui sont importants
comme et qui mérite d'être placés et
dans les conversations et dans les
écritures d'ailleurs si l'on considère
tous les journaux qui ont été écrits
par nos amis qui sont là ce soir le mot
homme revient dans vraiment à vous alors
que l'on ne perd plus de bourbon busset
mais alors si l'on considère jacques
tusset marcel joueur doué claude mauriac
là un autre véritablement dans le
journal intime et jeux de l'ère qu'il
faut avoir à la fois beaucoup de talent
beaucoup d'impudeur remarquable pour
entrer de cette manière là dans sa vie
privée et il faut être courageux d'une
certaine manière moi je n'ai pas ce
courage
bon alors si vous avez je trouve ça sous
la plume de vos confrères vous avez le
don d'amitié le don de sympathie et une
blonde a lorsqu'on lui demande quel est
votre profession il dit à me tirer
ah oui et alors effectivement vous parlé
avec beaucoup d'amitié de jean
d'élections tout à fait remarquable
delteil de luynes comme montherlant
chagall etc